The distribution of public keys is often
done through a certificate authority
or CA.
Alice sends a public key to the CA.
The CA verifies Alice's identification,
and
then creates a certificate of Alice's
public key and sends it to Alice.
The certificate contains time of
creation, validity period, and
the ID of Alice, and the public key.
And, it is signed using
a CA's public key.
Alice can then send this
certificate to any user, say Bob.
Or, Alice can publish it so
that any user can get it.
It is assumed that all users
have the CAs public key, and
therefore a user, say Bob,
can use the CAs public key
to verify the certificate and
obtain Alice's public key.
Likewise, Bob can get his
certificate and send it to Alice so
that Alice has Bob's public key.